maladie dégénérative qui entraîne la
perte progressive et irréversible des
fonctions mentales notamment de la
mémoire la maladie d'Alzheimer
toucherait plus de 30 millions de
personnes dans le monde dans l'Hexagone
une seule association de famille est
reconnu d'utilité publique dans ce
domaine France Alzheimer bonsoir donc à
Jacqueline Louette et à Jean-Manuel
coververt vous êtes bénévole de
l'association sur l'antenne de 50 ans en
Eveline le 13 avril 14h30 précisément
vous allez présenter votre gala pour
récolter des fonds la recherche a encore
et toujours besoin d'argent il est
important de récolter ces fonds oui tout
à fait oui oui et donc avec ce second
Gal là puisque c'est le dernier était Il
a 2 ans pour fêter les 10 ans de
l'association et bien on a essayé de
récolter le maximum de fond en faisant
venir le maximum de monde et c'est pour
ça que nous sommes là ce soir don et
argent récolté lors de ce Gal qui
serviront aussi bien la recherche qu'à
développer vos actions à quoi sert
concrètement cet argent tout à fait
alors cet argent servira pour les
chercheurs de l'in terme voilà mais
notre action sur le bassin de
Saint-Quentin elle est d'une part de
faire de l'écoute auprès des familles
d'autre part de les recevoir pour qu'ils
expose leur difficultés ou leur façon de
vivre immédiate ensuite on leur donne
éventuellement une formation gratuite il
y a plusieurs sessions qui leur sont
proposé dans le courant de l'année sur
le bassin de Saint-Quentin et on peut
les inclure éventuellement après un
groupe de parole nous en faisons deux
par mois parce qu'un groupe ne suffit
pas et on fait quelquefois des le gala
par exemple a un rôle festif on n'est
pas toujours dans la tristesse il y a
plusieurs structures qui existent sur le
département notamment à 5 an en ieline
la structure d' mer en TER on en a vu
quelques images vous travaillez avec ces
structures comment se passe le quotidien
pour vous sûr bien sûr bien sûr alors il
y il y a un accueil le jour au qu qui
reçoit les familles toute la semaine et
qui est ouvert depuis 2 ans à peu près
et qui maintenant est bien rempli et
fonctionne très bien les retours sont
satisfaisants à 99 % il faut le signaler
les les familles sont vraiment très très
cont contente très satisfaite de de ce
qui s'y passe et surtout du repos aussi
que les familles peuvent en en tirer
comme bénéfice mais il y a aussi le
l'enthousiasme des des patients à y
aller qui qui est important de souligner
et on travaille vraiment en harmonie
pour que l'on puisse développer aussi
des prestations de servicees de qualité
pour pouvoir recevoir les famille dans
de bonnes conditions on en vient à ce
garsl on va voir quelques images de
répétition que vous avez réalisé pour le
spectacle qui se déroulera le 13 avril
qui est mobilisé comment se passe ces
répétitions avec qui alors cette année c
associations sont mobilisées donc nous
aurons pour la danse la partie danse
infin danse et illicite danse que l'on
voit à l'écran pour la partie chanson le
groupe vocal imagine reviendra avec
également un duo d'auteur compositeur
les h song au niveau des arts du cirque
fax saabouge va mettre l'ambiance avec
ses jongleries et puis les 78 tours
reviendront pour de la magie et trois
magiciens sur scène donc un beau plateau
moins de monde mais avec plus de temps
pour chaque association c'était leur
vœux donc ça fait quand même 75
personnes qui vont défiler sur le
plateau et donc il y a un beau spectacle
en préparation il faut absolument venir
ça c'est c'est clair il y a encore des
places donc les réservations par
téléphone sont terminées mais il faut
encore se déplacer venir il y aura de la
place pour tout le monde c'est à partir
de 14h30 si on vient un petit peu avant
on pourra voilà ouverture des portes à
14h et puis donc normalement tout est
préparé pour que ça se passe bien au
niveau de la vente des billets tarif
entre 6 et 10 € hein alors gr 6 ans
c'est important de le signaler jusqu'à
18 ans 6 € les adultes à partir de 10 €
et on peut donner plus évidemment si le
cœur dit oui et toutes ces associations
se mobilisent facilement d'une année sur
l'a pas de souci moi je je sais que avec
Jacqueline on va dans les forums des
associations et donc
les spontanément elles disent oui et
donc après on monte un projet ensemble
je vais les voir en répétition et puis
voilà ça se construit tout simplement on
VO des images de l'an dernier voilà
c'était a 2 ansétait 2 ans c'était donc
c'était passé le gala vous aviez récolté
combien les précédentes années alors
c'était pas loin moins de 1000 € oui
autour de 1000 € parce qu'effectivement
après il y a des frais évidemment mais
voilà on dégage de l'argent et puis
surtout on donne un grand moment de joie
et un moment festif aux familles et aux
personnes qui n'ont parfois rien à voir
avec la maladie et donc c'est important
d'avoir un un vrai moment de partage
comme ça les associations interviennent
en tant que bénévolle sur le oui oui il
y a pas question d'argent entre nous
c'est vraiment un geste solidaire et
c'est pour ça que on est apprécié parce
que ça se passe en toute simplicité
c'est festif aussi vous nous l'avez dit
mais ça permet d'en savoir plus sur sur
la maladie maladie dont la découverte
remonte à 1906 l'association dit encore
avoir à lutter contre les idées reçues
ça peut paraître surprenant plus d'un
siècle après quelles sont les idées les
plus reçues autour de cette maladie
d'Alzheimer que c'est lié à la
vieillesse aussi par exemple tout à fait
alors qu'il y a des malades qui ont
moins de 60 ans ce common appelle les
malades jeunes et ça pose vraiment de de
gros gros problèmes pour les familles
qui ont ascendant descendants à charge
quelquefois conjoint ascendant
descendant à charge et c'est vraiment
très très difficile je pense que là il y
a il y a un gros un gros effort à faire
on on en accompagne pas mal sur le
bassin de Saint-Quentin et les groupes
de paroles leur sont ouverts c'est une
maladie qui évolue vite qui évolue
comment et bien je pense que là c'est
chaque chaque chaque cas est particulier
je crois que là moi je peux en parler un
petit peu c'est variable parce que j'ai
accompagné donc ma mère jusqu'à très peu
il y a peu et donc ça a duré 9 ans je
l'ai accompagné et donc ça a duré assez
longtemps et c'est vrai que c'est une
maladie qui efface la personne qui
effectivement elle termine dans un dans
un triste état et donc ça ça dépend des
personnes c'est très variable et c'est
très dur à vivre aussi pour l'entourage
c'est aussi pour ça que l'association
français ex voà c'est vraiment une
association au service des familles
parce que ça touche toute la famille pas
uniquement l'individu et ça concerne de
plus en plus de monde aussi les chiffres
sont plutôt inquiétants autour de des
perspectives d'évolution de de de la
maladie quels sont les signes déjà
peut-être qui doivent alerter et qui
doivent amener l'entourage à se
rapprocher d'association comme la vôtre
est-ce qu'il y a des sign actuellement
il y a 200000
personnes apparemment identifiées tous
les ans en plus je pense que là dès
qu'il y a des petits symptômes de de
perte de mémoire ou de changement de
comportement c'est surtout ça changement
d'humeur changement de comportement qui
sont souvent perceptibles que par la
famille il faut faut faut consulter de
façon à se à être très en avance pour la
pour avoir le diagnostic et la
connaissance pour un accompagnement de
qualité je pense que là c'est c'est très
très important de pouvoir être dans une
une anticipation et venir à nos
formations également puisque on délivre
6 séances de 3h gratuitement pour que
les personnes aient une connaissance
pour savoir quel chemin prendre le plus
simplement possible et ne que les
familles n'aillent pas à l'épuisement un
chiffre 225000 nouveaux cas diagnostiqué
chaque année la maladie qui progresse si
rien ne change le pays la France compa
1275000 personnes malades dans seulement
8 ans o où on est la recherche est-ce
qu'elle avance malhe alors il y a des
plein de choses qui sont en
développement il y a des vac qui sont en
développement il y a des nouvelles
molécules qu'on teste il y a des
techniques d'immunothérapie
effectivement qui sont en mais c'est
très long il y a des phases de recherche
certaines sont validées d'autres non
donc il y a des espoirs qui étaient
portés au niveau des vaccins qui n'ont
pas abouti donc voilà mais par contre ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir qu'à
chaque fois avec ces recherches on
progresse dans la dans une meilleure
connaissance de la maladie donc ce n'est
pas peine perdue mais effectivement il y
a pas de résultat spectaculaire pour le
moment il faut de l'argent pour aider la
recherche voilà pourquoi ce gar là est
important je redonne la date ce sera le
13 avril à partir de 14h30 au prisme à
hencour avec plusieurs associations
mobilisées 75 personnes sur scène voilà
qui vont défiler oui entre 6 10 € voir
gratuit pour les plus jeunes mais vous
pouvez bien sûr donner plus si vous le
souhaitez merci à vous je redonne aussi
ce chiffre he la maladie d'Alzheimer qui
touchait environ 26 millions de
personnes dans le monde en 2005 qui
pourrai en toucher quatre fois plus en